only 330 miles south of
where we're sitting right now uh with
amazing weather weather
beautiful beaches a rich culture
intelligent hardworking amazing people
the people of cuba they should be living
in paradise
instead over the last five almost six
decades
we've had selfish power hungry
dictatorship
they have turned the island into a
communist hell hole
beginning in 1959 the castro regime
outlawed
private property confiscated hundreds of
thousands of homes and farms and
businesses
they nationalized all major corporations
and media outlets outlawed all dissent
they restricted air travel and yes they
murdered or imprisoned
anyone with the courage to speak out the
conditions are so bad that
for over 50 years the cuban people have
been
fleeing the island in droves look at
your screen
look at this perilous journey broken
down dilapidated rickety boats shark
infested waters
risking their lives in in makeshift
rafts and
inner tubes even and literally anything
that will float
in the hope of making it to the shores
of america and getting one foot on dry
land
now today those still living in cuba
they face these dire conditions
many are risking their lives this very
night most
are forced to now imagine this live on
less than a dollar a day
food is scarce we have the cuban people
waiting in line for
hours for a government allowance oh you
get
five eggs a month per person
and you get a few pounds of rice per
month along with two
kilograms of meat every 10 days
milk it's only provided for pregnant
women and children
under seven i'm not making any of this
up
this is communism this is a murdering
communist dictatorship
soap toothpaste basic medicine even
aspirin hard to find building materials
even more scarce
cuba's once great cities are now
crumbling the roads are nearly
impassable
and the cars i never saw so many 1950
models cars seemingly held together with
super glue and string and frankly
ingenuity
of people that have no other choices but
believe it or not
even in cuba today the horse and
carriage
is still a widespread mode of
transportation in much of cuba
and as i point out in chapter four my my
book that i wrote before the election
live free or die
socialism and its history of failure
whatever name
whatever manifestation any way it's been
tried
these promises are never kept it always
results in dishonesty
broken unfulfilled promises
more poverty not less poverty and then
when it's all said and done how much
freedom did you give up in the name of
false promises of security
a case in point fidel castro promised a
state-of-the-art socialist utopia
a worker's paradise free of any and all
outside influences
instead he turned this once prosperous
country
into a destitute wasteland totally
dependent on foreign nations
cuba today imports almost all of its
food and other basic supplies from
vietnam south america and yes even the
united states
in the 1960s cuba attempted to import
nuclear missiles
from the former soviet union which
brought the world to a brink of a
nuclear war
more recently cuba's close ties with
russia china
iran venezuela continues to cause
serious problems
specifically security problems for this
country the united states
one example 2016 american diplomats in
havana
were reportedly attacked with microwave
radiation
from a weapon system guess what deployed
by
russian technology this kind of hostile
behavior from cuba's dictatorship
further isolates this island nation from
the rest of the world
and it does nothing to improve the lives
of the great people of cuba
of course while millions go hungry those
in power may never miss a meal
and still amid the ongoing protests
and in spite of many efforts to prevent
the world from seeing what's
actually happening cubans aren't crying
out for more
food medicine and no joe biden they're
not
crying out for more covert vaccines they
are crying out for liberty and freedom
things as americans we all too often
take for granted
the freedom of speech the freedom of the
press the freedom of religion and
movement
and and the god-given right to pursue
happiness we believe in america
we're endowed by our creator natural
rights granted by
god endowed by our creator and if joe
biden is watching not uh endowed by the
thing
you know the thing the thing is god the
creator of everything joe
now we unequivocally support those brave
men and women in cuba tonight
they're putting their lives at risk
they're seeking liberty
they're seeking freedom we all pray that
they succeed
now we freedom-loving americans we do
stand in solidarity with the people of
cuba
as they are risking their lives this
very night to free
these great people from tyranny and
poverty hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else